Diane you had some other projects and
things that you worked with him on I
would like you wait we never had
projects that way in that sense he was
the most loyal person I've known in my
life from the day I met him first words
out of his mouth after we saw the test
we were in this little room and he I
said to myself humor means a lot to me
in my life I'm a serious person so
anyone who wants to be funny because
it's fun it's wonderful
Robert was that he made light he brought
you out of adult room he made you
doesn't hated complaining
you don't call Robert and complain about
your life otherwise it's over
so the loyalty was there and the first
things he said to me whispered in my ear
watching the test and black and white
for this Fox contract he said your dog
your voice is so high the dogs could
hear it and it was true and so I thought
this is a person but he was loyal every
year Carolyn knows this every year every
time he came to LA he would call and say
I'm rounding up the group and he had
dinner I would usually have it at my
house or we go to a restaurant at
somewhere it was Carole cook and handful
of 3/4 people and I was able to bring
some of my friends students and teachers
to meet him at various times because
they loved movies too and he was so
gracious so wonderful and the best thing
was in San Francisco when you were there
and we all had dinner and Robert agreed
to come to the Academy where I was
teaching and he interviewed envied coats
on our stage he offered he said I wanna
interview would you mind if I came in it
I said Robert this is fantastic so he
came over and he interviewed her and got
to meet all these young people so I want
to thank you Randy because it's so
important that the young people know
Robert as
so we owe it to them to give them a
spirit a beautiful spirit of
thoughtfulness of kindness of love
everything anyone saying here tonight is
true and more so so in the in the truest
sense we owe it to him to carry on this
and it's not just about his passion for
movies it's about the kindness and the
love that he exuded the quality and the
I can't say that when he walked in you
felt a presence it exude
interest in other people he never was
self aggrandizing or any kind of thing
like that it was always how are you
doing what are you doing tell me about
the job I even asked him what should I
ask for a salary I mean it was it was
that far I could what do i what should I
do with this idea of deechi what's the
salary going to be and he said well if
you have to love it you have to want to
do it you have to be passionate so for
all of the young people here tonight
that I hope will stay for the film it's
a treasure and it was his favorite one
of his favorites